all right so dark solder them due out
till the first half of next year and
it's bound to go through a ton of
changes but if you're a Souls fan you
love to pick up the intricacies I've had
to spend a few hours with the recent
Gamescom demo but one name go wouldn't
let us record the playthrough I'm going
to give you a detailed rundown on the
state of Dark Souls threes mechanics so
in this demo you can pick from two
pre-made classes the wandering Knight in
the northern warrior aside from the
armor the obvious differences are that
the nightma script with a broadsword and
the northern warrior has a one-handed
math stats weren't present in this demo
so combat it definitely feels dark souls
as opposed to blood-borne the first
thing I noticed was that the Dark Souls
1 kick is back for God breaking just
hold the direction with your left analog
stick and hit r1 at the same time
there are two types of shields right now
one that lets you Parry and riposte with
l2 and one that lets you perform the
Nuart attacks by holding l2 there's a
little icon next to this show that shows
you what function it has arts attacks
use up what I'm gonna call arts points
of which you get 20 this is refreshed at
each bonfire just like your Estus flask
the broadsword is the wandering Knights
default weapon and it's arts move is
already stance which gives you access to
a secondary light and heavy attack
variation these do more damage than a
regular attack in each slash uses one
arts point the one-handed axe is the
northern warriors default weapon the
arts move it has is a barbarian style
fus-ro-dah which stuns enemies and gives
you a small damage boss I found myself
using this one a lot at combo an enemy
and when it would start its attack
string I'd stun it with the shout to
reset its state letting me continue with
another combo the great sword you find
has an arts move which looks like a
quick stomp forward it kind of looks
like an on-the-ground attack a parry or
a guard break but I really wasn't able
to connect it on basic enemies in these
kind of scenarios if you hit r2 during
the step there you perform a big upward
slash the jewel scimitars you find have
a 212 as the arts mail which attacks in
an area around you
it's a 212 regardless of whether you
have it equipped in sword and board
style or intuited form with one scimitar
in each hand it's a pretty fast weapon
so it's easy to follow up the art attack
with a regular combat
alright so riposte maybe it's been a
while for me but they felt easier to do
and easy to
and they gave you invincibility finding
the sweet spot for backstabbing also
felt easier and it also makes you
invincible which some people might not
be too happy about enemies can also
backstab you and enemies can also change
stances so for instance some of the
bigger nine enemies changed from sword
and board style to two-handed sword
stances just like you can coming
straight from blood-borne dodging didn't
feel as reliable in the Dark Souls demo
I won't spoil the monsters that surprise
me but I'll say the demo was swarming
with lots of enemies / mob and mobs that
crawl up from the edge of the stage and
a lot of those enemies had sweeping
attacks which meant dodging a lot
usually put me in a really bad position
you know it's that classic solid
geometry track I thought things were
more effective when they used my shelf
to block attacks and control the space
which is great because that's Dark Souls
alright so the arms you can find in the
demo are the green blossom which gives
you stamina regen pine resin which buffs
your weapon with fire fire bombs
throwing knives and of course the estus
flask which you can still charged with
multiple button presses to get multiple
heals so nothing new here the demo
didn't have stat screens equipped
screens or a holing mechanic so that's
all up in the air at this point but I
can confirm that the praise the sun
gesture is back so don't need to worry
that's the state of the game post
gamescom 2015 it's 2 out in the first
half of next year but hopefully we'll
see a lot more new stuff so as always be
sure to stay tuned to games part where
we'll keep you updated on Dark Souls 3